Whatever this bullshit is,
I don't got time for it, okay?
Our daddy killed that reporter.
You got a sick mind, Jesse.
That's exactly
what I've been sayin' to him.
It's obvious.
Stop talkin' shit on Daddy!
You don't know Daddy
as well as you think you do.
Judy, you need a ride?
-Yeah, I'll take one.
-Then, get one.
♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Dad can't shoot
worth a shit.
I'll shoot you. Go to your room
right now.
This damn family has everything
in the world,
but you can't
just all get along.
Everybody in the church knows
that your husband is a joke.
You roller blade?
It's an exercise I do
to keep swole.
JESSE GEMSTONE:
The fuck is that?
KELVIN GEMSTONE:
It's Daddy's phone.
"Last night reminded me
of old times.
I set 'em up,
you knock 'em down."
Knock 'em down means kill.
And kill means murder.
And murder causes death.
What kind of baptism is this?
Today is the day that T.J.
is gon' be born again.
B.J.
Who's ready to meet T.J. 2.0?!
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
We were attacked.
Don't get involved.
I need some fellas to help
handle some business
-down in Memphis.
-Tennessee?
Yeah, Gregory. Is there
another fuckin' Memphis?
Well, actually, there is.
There's this little ancient city
in Egypt--
All right, well, we're not
going to Ancient Egypt,
you motherfucker.
We have been having
some epic hangs.
JESSE: Oh, we sure have.
JUDY GEMSTONE:
Let's make God proud today.
I can do that.
If you come along,
the impoverished family
are ready to take
their photo.
They're so excited
over such a small amount.
Yeah, like, 50,000 dollars
is like barely any money.
Poor people love money, y'all.